when you dream
do you see like visually see your
surroundings this exact same way because
i don't like i mean like when i'm okay
like i'm seeing this right now right i'm
seeing like the the real world in like i
don't
it's like way fuzzier when i see things
in my dreams like i let's say i know
there's a table there yeah but i can't
like give you the detail of it like i
can i can i know what everything is
around me yeah i know everything's
around me but i can't like visually see
everything that's happening really
strange do you have this as well no
mine's mine's in like [ __ ] rtx on 4k
60 fps man why is it like a fisheye lens
that's that's why like for me that's why
like for me it's sometimes it's like so
hard for me to tell the difference
between when i'm dreaming and when i'm
awake because my dreams are so vivid and
so
i don't know like i said they have a lot
of depth to them that sometimes i wake
up and
sometimes i immediately know that i've
just woken up and sometimes it takes me
a few
few moments to realize okay i'm i'm
actually awake now this is the real
world i'm not i'm not in the dream world
anymore i think for me things that are
fuzzy is things that don't exist in
reality huh so it's like like if it's
like a table for instance then it's like
i can clearly see that it's a table but
if it's like a [ __ ] fairy then i'll
be then then it'll probably look fuzzy
well you know when you're you're trying
to remember a moment that happened yeah
right
you have a picture of it in your head
you don't have it like in 4k rtx the way
that you saw it right it's not this kind
of fuzzy
you remember where everything was you
think you you know what i mean yeah yeah
the way that you recall things that
happened it's kind of like that the way
i see stuff in dreams it's like i don't
see it perfectly like if i'm focusing on
like this table yeah i know god's there
for example but i can't like see gone
does that make sense
like yeah
i
i don't see them unless i'm then paying
attention to them
yeah because then your brain has to
render out right it's rendering
because because you know it's there but
like your brain's just like i didn't
want to render his thoughts
i know that god's there i just don't
want to render it now you're going to
upgrade your brain
now right i don't need to see that joe's
in the corner of my eye yeah because
it's in the corner of my arm but when
i'm trying to remember the whole picture
in my head when i'm in the dream it's
like that yeah
rendering right right where it's like a
1060.
my draw distance is like lowest possible
like when i'm walking up to the building
it starts to come in a frame it's like
it's it's a load of [ __ ]
a weird [ __ ] dream what a weird [ __ ]
it's like that though where like i the
dream doesn't exist unless i'm focusing
on it in the dream so have you ever had
a dream that's taken place in somewhere
that you're like very familiar with or
like somewhere like you know all of my
dreams are in places that i've been to
in real life right see most of most of
the time my dreams are in new places
that i'm not aware of
i don't know what it is i think my brain
is like
capable of coming up with new locations
what i think it is i think it's like
stitching together things that i've seen
passing right yeah yeah yeah yeah
and and what i
you know like i can i can't
visualize a lot of things but i i just
know what's happening and i have an idea
it's really strange a lot of my dreams
are in my house they take place in my
house that's strange i never have dreams
in my house
but it's like all sorts of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happens
in my house that shouldn't work which
house
like the house
it's like games start you just wait you
just starts in a weird-ass location and
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on no
it's always it's always mid-conversation
yeah i never remember the story i'm just
like oh wait what oh i guess we're here
now yeah cause i i guess i only remember
my dreams when i realized i'm in a dream
so i never remember how i get there yeah
you know like that so i don't see like
the playstation
it's just like oh i'm in the game i'm
just like oh dreamcast starts it's
brilliant
it's almost weird because i feel i feel
like when i'm dreaming i'm watching like
a video
and at some point in the video i'll know
that's me does that make sense
like it's a series of events unfolding
yeah and i'm not necessarily constantly
in that brain of the person experiencing
it this is so strange right this is
really weird even even stranger question
have you ever dreamed in third person
yeah yeah okay okay that to me is like
the weirdest [ __ ] dream because like
like for some reason in my dream it
makes sense that i'm seeing myself in
third person yeah okay right
like for example
like even though i've never experienced
that in my life yeah that prison one
yeah it was weird because i remember
that's just gonna start to be strange i
had i remember shooting the guns right
right but then i also remember watching
me
after shooting the guns
so it flicks between first and third
place
and the weird thing is is that i then
was able to feel the emotions of both
yeah when doing the the dream act and
then when watching me do the dream act
yeah this is so this is so strange i've
never spoken about this i've never
spoken about this before you're talking
now that you're making me think about
this i'm realizing how weird this sounds
to say out loud like this must sound so
bizarre i don't know if anyone else is i
don't think a dream conversation is
going to be normal i've never had a
conversation just about my dreams before
with anyone but like so the best way i
can describe how it is like is like you
know when you're like in playing halo
right yeah and there's that theater mode
yeah where just any point you can just
unclip from the camera yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like just but i i'm not choosing where
the camera goes but i'm seeing it from a
perspective and i don't understand whose
or what it is sometimes yeah sometimes
sometimes i have like amazing
cinematography
and i don't know i don't know how like
if only the youtube videos could be yeah
yeah
right like i don't know i don't know how
it happens but sometimes i sometimes i'm
in first person and then i like i go to
like a new
a new like an area or something and i
have there's this really
area
a new area on the map or something and
i'm like my dream switches to like this
establishing shot of this like new this
new landscape on a minute
and i'm just like i don't know and i
remember thinking in the dream damn that
looks cool as [ __ ] and then i load back
into my character or something
it's so i i don't know how to describe
it
your dream has cut scenes is that what
you're saying
this man's dream literally has cutscenes
and when it's over he goes back into
first person
holy [ __ ] it's it's so it's i don't know
why like i think sometimes i dream in
games these drums sound like a kojima
game yeah sometimes i dream in games and
sometimes i dream in movies which is why
like it never makes sense to me how i
can possibly dream in third person and
like at the time it makes sense because
like you never see yourself in third
place my third person do you mean like
like in a movie like from a movie camera
standpoint or are we talking like gta
like behind yourself sometimes both
really yeah yeah yeah so yeah i think
it's
it's weird really because again i know
that i'm in this situation and i fully
understand that it's a dream
but i never ever like think that like
this is wrong yeah yeah because i'm in
the moment and it's what my mind is
making up so it always feels natural
when i'm in this dream like for some
reason i'm just [ __ ] remember this
now like talk to you guys
every time i'm in an interrogation room
i'm never like
it's never pov interrogation room it's
always it's interrogation
it's always side view like this is
[ __ ] jcs criminal investigations or
something it's so it's so weird i don't
know why i mean like i do every anytime
i have a conversation in interrogation
room i'm always in third person i don't
know why but
it always feels like i'm in control
of what i'm saying i'm sure that's
purely because we've just like consumed
media that where they portray those
things like that right so yeah yeah i'd
be interested to see
if another person who has never seen
like an interrogation scene in a movie
how they would because i've never been
in an interrogation in my life so that's
i guess it
kind of makes sense i i've also found
that if i'm highly anxious about
something when going to bed there's like
a 90 chance my dream is going to be
about that oh that sounds that's only
ever happened a few times and that's
only ever happened with homework and
exams
i was playing that uh pogo stuck game
recently yeah and um
and i yeah i had like nightmares that i
was stuck in this game
and that i couldn't stop playing this
game because i couldn't beat it because
i was making i played it for like eight
hours and i made no progress
and then i went to bed all i could feel
was me playing the game in the dream and
then i was playing it and i was like i
couldn't get out it's horrible
that was a nice that's a true
horrible night
that's a scarier nightmare than uh you
dying yeah the worst part was i knew i
was in a nightmare and i was getting
more annoyed because like why am i
wasting time where i could be actually
doing this but instead i'm in the
nightmare
stuck in a cycle playing it in my
nightmare
do you ever have like moments where your
dream is so intense that you don't feel
like you've slept at all
yeah i don't understand like i wake up
more tired yeah yeah yeah yeah i never
had that yeah because sometimes because
you go on such an emotional journey in
this dream or at least i do that i wake
up just like exhausted so what do you do
then just get another eight hours huh i
i don't i like i get up but like i get
up but like my sometimes i just like
feel like i haven't slept at all just
because i feel like i was awake in my
dreams so i didn't really sleep at all i
don't know it's it's it's really weird
yeah like the worst nightmares i've had
is i go to sleep obviously tired and i'm
probably not in like a right state of
mind yeah before i go to bed hence the
reason why i have the nightmare and then
i have that nightmare i wake up in that
[ __ ] cold sweat like
[ __ ] yeah i'm so tired after that but i
don't want to go back to bed
because i'm go i know if i close my eyes
right now it's just going to be like to
be continued like it's just going to
happen again
why is it where you have a fun dream you
can never get back into the dream yeah
when you have a nightmare nightmares
when you have a nightmare you go back to
sleep you re-enter the nightmare i think
it's like pretty stress and stuff
i find it so much easier to re-enter my
nightmares than to re-enter my fun
dreams